hi there uh day 68. it was a beautiful
day i've uh walked the dog in the sun
again in the forest
uh i want to talk about time time and
language learning
time is ultimately the
rarest resource that we have
in life i mean it's the ultimate
non-renewable resource we can't make it
we can make products we can plant stuff
in the ground and it'll grow
but we can't make time
so
uh when it comes to language learning we
have a limited amount of time available
because we have other activities
and so we have to make decisions like
today
it's a lovely day my wife went to play
golf
so i was tempted to play golf
but then i would get
no uh korean studying done
we're going out to dinner tonight
so if it weren't for the 90-day
challenge i probably would have gone to
play golf
in the end i studied korean
and then i also walked the dog for a
good hour and a half
uh
which was great i loved it
so in the end i was thinking of this you
know if i'd gone to play golf i would
have enjoyed my golf
and that's all i would have gotten out
of it i would have got the
whatever my wife played nine holes so
you know two and a half hours or so of
enjoyment
minus the time driving there and back
uh
and when i drive there with my wife i
can't listen to korean
uh so instead i did probably three hours
here at home between linking and reading
on my ipad
and then i had another hour and a half
in the bush while listening
and walking the dog
so and that was enjoyable maybe not as
enjoyable as playing golf
but enjoyable nevertheless however you
know when you look at time you can just
think about this you know there are
those activities
which basically the enjoyment or lack of
enjoyment is basically all contained in
the activity
i guess playing golf there's some
benefit in that you're out in the fresh
air then there are those activities that
may or not may or may not be enjoyable
but they have
an effect an impact a result a
consequence that consequence may be good
or bad so i you know i think you know
anytime you have a decision on how to
spend your time
if you choose to spend your time getting
drunk
you know that might be enjoyable but it
might be have might have some rather
unpleasant consequences
uh
if you like in my own case i find
studying flashcards not all that
enjoyable
i might do it while i'm waiting you know
or for my food in a restaurant or
something
i wouldn't spend an hour or an hour and
a half doing flashcards because it's not
enjoyable but it probably has some
benefit i'm not sure of that but i'm
sure it has some benefit i should say it
does have some benefit i'm not sure how
much benefit it has on the other hand
i'm walking the dog which is good for
the dog and also
gets me some
brownie points with my son and his
family and
my wife's mother my
son's mother-in-law
so there's some benefit there i think
anytime you're you're doing something
for someone else
because we operate on the basis of
reciprocity you feel good about doing it
and you're contributing towards a
reciprocal
favor benefit that those other people
are going to bestow back are you
so the dog's benefiting
my wife's mother-in-law's her mother my
son's mother-in-law is happy
uh i'm getting exercise and i'm
listening to korean
wow and by listening to korean
i know from experience you know how much
enjoyment i get from
watching a movie and
as we all do watching a movie in a
foreign language
my wife is watching curling on tv it
doesn't matter whether it's the russian
girls uh talking to each other screaming
you know
uh or you know japanese korean i don't
quite get it yet but i'll get some words
um you know they're swiss gals i don't
if they're into s
swiss german i don't understand it but
um
so that you get all of this benefit so
all i'm saying is
it's difficult to find the time
to study
a language uh
i prefer to find things to do that i
find enjoyable and that i know are going
to give me benefit such as my focus on
listening and reading
and
when faced with the decision as to
whether i should
do the sort of studying activity
or do something which is not related to
studying
um it's always a close call but certain
um certain decisions are made for me i
play my hockey three times a week
but the optional ones it's often a
toss-up so
sometimes i'll say oh well i'll go and
play golf although it may that may not
be
high on my agenda makes my wife happy so
i get some reciprocal benefit there so
anyway just philosophizing about
time
and how
you know we can't stretch time
but we can get more benefit out of our
use of time if our activity is both
beneficial to us possibly beneficial to
others and has other long-term
benefits that are going to
bring benefit later on ultimately what
we want is to maximize happiness not
just the immediate short-term happiness
but sort of
a constant state
of happiness
a because of what we choose to do at a
given point in time and b because of
what we invest in
activities health
knowledge
uh helping friends etc
being a good citizen like picking up my
dog's poo when i go and walk the dog
in the expectation that others will do
the same
so that we're living in a society where
people are responsible towards each
other and that makes all of our lives
more pleasant and i think that's a large
part of why we contribute to these
various social programs that help people
who are less lucky
because a lot of us who are better off
have just been lucky in most cases
so anyway i thought i'd philosophize
well beyond the issue of time but time
is the ultimate
scarce rare commodity when it comes to
language learning
so we all have to make decisions as to
how we
find the time and how we spend the time
in our language learning i hope all that
makes sense the more i talk the less
sense it makes to me
bye for now